out of Malaysia where the lower house of
parliament is voting to abolish a
mandatory death penalty for crimes such
as murder and drug trafficking the bills
seek to substitute the death penalty
with life imprisonment of between 30 and
40 years as well as caning let's go live
to our correspondent Florence Louis in
Kuala Lumpur Florence this is something
that's been in discussion for several
years now
that's right in 2018 it was actually
part of the manifesto of the Coalition
that eventually won that Year's General
polls to abolish the mandatory death
penalty but during its two years in
power that Administration failed to
introduce to reform the the laws and
then last year we had a different
Administration tabling similar bills but
before they could be debated Parliament
was dissolved and here we are in 2023
again a different Administration tabling
those bills and members of parliament
are expected to vote on it on Monday it
is expected to pass because it has
bipartisan support now the mandatory
death penalty or the death penalty even
has been part of the Malaysia's Criminal
Justice System since British colonial
rule but it was originally enforced for
murder and then when Malaysia toughened
its drug laws in the 1980s to show that
it has zero tolerance on drugs it made
the death penalty mandatory for drug
trafficking but the conversation around
the death penalty has been taking place
around the world for decades now there's
been an understanding that the mandatory
death penalty is not only unjust because
mainly it takes away the discretionary
factors of the judge but also it doesn't
allow them to take into consideration
mitigating factors like the person's
history of abuse or mental illness so
that conversation about reforming the
just the sentencing system has been
taking place for several years now in
Malaysia
vanitha dawit's husband has been on
death row for 13 years he was found
guilty of murder
she's raised their son on her own
when my son went to kindergarten he
didn't have a father it was just me a
single mom when he started primary
school he didn't have a father then
either he's now 16. his father has not
even held his hand
Malaysia is now aiming to abolish the
mandatory death penalty they are
currently 11 offenses where death is the
automatic punishment
of the thousand three hundred inmates on
death row nearly 70 percent were
convicted of drug trafficking
in Malaysia carrying even a small amount
of illicit substance comes under that
definition
human rights groups say it doesn't meet
the threshold of most serious crimes
under international law
the proposed amendments will allow the
country's highest court to replace death
sentences with life imprisonment and
caning these reforms have been on the
table for several years now and a
moratorium on executions has been in
place since 2018. the minister in charge
of legal reforms says the abolition of
the mandatory death penalty is aimed at
valuing the sanctity of Life while
ensuring Justice and fairness for all
anti-death penalty Advocates welcome the
move and say Malaysia also needs to look
at reforming other aspects of its penal
system including rehabilitation
most of us in Asia Pacific specifically
still really prioritizes punitive
punishment we don't really ask the hard
question once we punish a guy and once
they come out what we want to do with
him do we expect him to suddenly
reintegrate back to society and do good
or do we expect them to reoffend on the
road
for vanitha there is at least a chance
that her husband's case might be
reviewed
I know he did wrong but please don't
hang him give him another chance release
him he can change
the changes will still have to be passed
in the Upper House of Parliament and
signed into law by the king before they
come into effect
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur
so you know many activists and
anti-death penalty Advocates say their
ultimate goal is to see the death
penalty abolished in Malaysia completely
Malaysia is one of 53 countries that
still maintains the death penalty so
more than 70 around 70 percent of
countries in the world have abolished
the death penalty in law and in practice
but some activists some Advocates are
very realistic they don't expect that
conversation to take place in Malaysia
at least for another 10 years and that
is mainly because many people still see
the death penalty as an effective
deterrent even though there's no data to
say that it is and there's also the
perception that to abolish the death
penalty could show that the country or
the administration is soft on crime so
that conversation has to take place
first before that's expected the death
penalty can be completely abolished
Florence thank you for that Florence
Louis live there in Kuala Lumpur